in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Nigel
and Brianna are with us welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show hey Dave we're so
excited to be here well we're honored to
have you where do you two live East
Texas lyndale okay very cool welcome to
Nashville and you're here to do your
debt-free scream finally I love it and
how much have you paid off one hundred
and eleven thousand two hundred ninety
dollars love it and how long did that
take forever 63 months 63 months Wow
that's real and what kind of range of
income during that time fifty thousand
up to 115 plus hopefully by the end of
this year Wow nice increase though
during that five year period of time so
what are you two do for a living I'm a
tree farmer I do I do a special project
for a commercial tree farm and she does
medical recruiting from home okay very
cool very cool
so what's caused your all's income to go
up over double during this five years I
started working from home and my husband
is a very hard worker and he's gotten
several promotions it was very hard for
us very good good that's awesome
so what kind of debt was the hundred
eleven thousand everything it was two
student loans two vehicles hospital debt
a credit card to buy window it's pretty
much everything well you are normals
broke yeah a little bit of every kind of
debt so what happened five years and
three months ago I'm so glad you asked
so we were at church and our church was
gonna offer Financial Peace University
and Nigel said oh it's one of those
crazy guys who wants you to sell your
vehicle and walk to work or something
yeah and I said we should really do this
cuz I'm the nerd and we we were teaching
on Wednesday nights teaching youth and
so we got a home kit and we listened to
him kind of but in April of 2011 we came
to Nashville to visit family and we came
to the studio and you were gone at an
event but we got to talk to Martha when
she was still here and she gave us the
DVD set Wow we went home and watched it
in a week and then that following week
Nigel sold his truck oh and walked to
work you traded it for two less
expensive vehicles and then I in turn
sold my car right after that and we were
just hardcore that first couple months
so we got rid of a lot of debt and then
we had our second child and then we kind
of the three years in between we just
kind of stayed afloat
we never added debt but we we weren't
using envelopes the whole time and we
weren't doing you lost your emotional
momentum yes okay all right oh my gosh
okay
and so it was a year ago a year ago our
church was doing Financial Peace
University and we were coordinators for
a class and that is what that's what
changed everything Nigel I'm the nerd I
know that's hard to believe that's what
changed everything Nigel was completely
on board a year ago and we just we just
put everything towards it he got a
couple bonuses and I think that was hard
just putting that you got that big chunk
of money yeah that was a you're a
coordinator it's kind of like you're
kind of like under the Mike Maginot file
absolutely there's nothing more tough
than teaching something to make you do
it
right and what was really neat with that
and the groups were every generation was
in our group and so we had people a lot
older than ask people younger than us
and it was so neat because everybody was
kind of on the same page and then we had
cheerleaders and it was it was just a
bit it was a really neat experience and
they're cheering us on right now that
was awesome and then a cool school a
cool story because you know the Lord is
all in all in our journey the very the
very last payment we made I went to the
mailbox on a Saturday morning and I got
an escrow check and it was literally
within dollars of what we owed
everything and so I just stood at the
mailbox and I had tears in my eyes and I
showed him and I said this is how we
know we're doing the right thing it was
pretty amazing that's pretty neat
there's like God just winking at you
yeah very nice very fun so how much of
the 111,000 happened in the last 12 or
14 months then 21,000 okay
so you got you got on fire and just
knocked it out then absolutely okay very
cool and that the income increases
recent and so now I mean the sky's the
limit we're so excited we talked all the
way from Texas just on what we're going
to do and how much we're gonna give and
we over-tipped today for lunch and it
was really fun it is fun all right and
the three girls are with you and what
are their names
Addison turns seven yesterday at Kinley
will be five next month
and Caroline is three okay forget it and
they've got specialized t-shirts for
those of you not watching on YouTube you
can see the t-shirts and when they line
up the three beautiful little blonde
girls it says weird one says weird the
next one says debt and the next one says
free so I'm not sure the one that the
middle child had to wear the word bad
that's that's like the typical yeah
she'll make it yeah well my middle child
is gonna make it that's Rachel stay bad
that's fun well congratulations
beautiful beautiful family very very
proud of you thank you for everything
that you do
guys you're the heroes man I mean you
did this stuff you changed that yourself
and now you're coordinating a class and
so passing it on that's absolutely
incredible and looking at those three
girls it's worth it no doubt very cool
and of course we've got a signed copy of
Chris Hogan's new book retire inspired
number one best-selling book for you as
our gift because that's the next chapter
become very wealthy and overtip for the
rest of your life that's pretty cool
yeah three weddings to pay for he's not
worried about college he's worried about
weddings smart way very smart man I love
it well very well done you guys very
well done all right it's Nigel and
Brianna
or is it Brianna I guess and Brianna and
Addison and Kenley and Caroline we're
debt-free a hundred and eleven thousand
dollars paid off in sixty three months
most of it in the last twelve to
fourteen making fifty two now 115 count
it down girls
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one
that's right
well done so perfect man I love it I
love it I love it
well done oh that's how it's done good
stuff
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you can do this you know that
really is a message whether you've got
two hundred seventy thousand dollars in
student loan debt or 27 thousand well
you've got a fifty thousand dollar
income or $500,000 in common